samsung just released another pair of
earbuds these are the galaxy butts too
and today we will compare them not only
to the airpods pro but also the amazing
beats studio buds and see which one of
these is worth the money not only we're
gonna compare the design and comfort
we're gonna take a look at the sound
quality active noise cancellation the
microphones and much more i've owned
every pair of samsung earbuds and they
do a great job but it looks like this
time
they are really getting serious we have
active noise cancellation at 150 bucks
let's go ahead and pull out this little
case all right that looks nice and clean
same size as they've been using look at
that two tone that looks really nice i
love the color options and in general
the case is nice and small now it is
thicker than the airpods max case and a
little bit taller but definitely a lot
smaller than the beats as far as battery
life the air pods have the least for the
bud themselves four and a half hours
with active noise cancellation compared
to five on both of these and inside the
case it flips they have the most 24
hours plus compared to 20 hours of the
beats 2 and only 15 with the beats
studio buds and with that the beats are
also the only ones that don't have
wireless charging built into the case in
addition to usb type-c or lightning and
with that the design of the earbuds are
also very different we have stems with
airpods pro this bulbous design with the
buds too and this very unique minimalist
design with the beats studio buds that i
really like let's go ahead and pop these
in we'll talk about comfort these are
definitely really round
and that's essentially this is actually
very soft i think they've changed it
putting them into my ear all right i
mean i can instantly tell
the round design is literally hugging my
ear all around the outside i definitely
feel them a lot more than when i put in
my earpods pro these don't sit as tight
in there and of course we have that
little valve that releases the pressure
uh it doesn't make it feel like your
ears are plugged so as far as comfort
these are excellent probably the best
and these uh beets are also super nice
i'm not feeling them as much i have a
lot of experience with these around my
ears and they are also the lightest so
these are second place the controls are
also different across the board the
studio buds you actually have to press a
physical button which i do not love
because it kind of pushes them into your
ear more
the buds too they are a touch surface
so you can literally just tap on there
and it picks it up and actually does a
pretty good job samsung has gotten
really good at this and then of course
with the airpods pro you have the stem
and this is my favorite option you're
not forcing anything you have a little
click when you're actually pressing down
they work great and now let's get into a
very important part and that is active
noise cancellation i want to know how
good are the buds too at 150 bucks of
course the airpods pro let's toggle it
into that
they do a great job
wow let me go ahead and go to the buds
the beats studio buds these are also
very good i think for this room it
actually is even better just because it
seals so much more in
bam
excellent i feel like i hear a little
bit more of the higher noise through the
air vent but a little bit less of the
lower kind of deeper rumble and it
definitely plugs up my voice more so and
the moment of truth let's pull open
these buds right here
see how good can samsung do for 150
bucks let's toggle it
all right
interesting but go ahead and say
something hey man can you hear me i hear
you so i hear more
it's almost like a mix of both these let
me go back and forth a couple times
before i give you guys my verdict all
right guys so i went back and forth
through these a couple times before i
gave you guys my verdict and pretty much
these are in third place you hear more
of the high frequency sounds more of the
low frequency sounds and i guess that
kind of makes sense because samsung also
has their higher end galaxy buds pro so
they're probably tuning these down now
if you have not had active noise
cancellation if you have older galaxy
buds these are definitely gonna do a
good job you will be happy with them but
if you want the best active noise
cancellation either one of these two
options are better and now what about
transparency mode we know that the
airpod pros are the best in the market
let me switch here you sound you pretty
much hear what you normally would hear
without him would you go ahead and say
something hey man you sound fantastic
you sound excellent these are good let's
try out the
beats studio buds here all right go
ahead and say something how are those
man how do those sound
you actually sound not too bad i sound
pretty dang terrible i know there's been
a firmware update but as far as the room
sound
it sounds unnatural kind of filtered not
super digital my voice sounds digital
but it feels like it's halfway plugged
the microphones on these well you guys
will hear them in just a little bit and
let's go ahead and try out these guys
right here all right
huh that is weird
my voice is amplified more so i'm going
to go through the settings that vent is
way too low wait say that again
did samsung kill it you said uh-huh yes
you sound like an echo machine dude do
it
yes
that's weird
hey do that whistling again you just
whistle try that again
dude it's all staticky do it again okay
it's bad now that really has me thinking
how are the microphones going to be on
these things we will see in a sec but
first i want to do a sound quality
comparison listen to three songs you
guys can listen with us and see my
reaction my first reaction to the sound
quality of these
[Music]
okay okay okay guys
interesting these are good
these are honestly plentifully surprised
it's basically like if you took the
airpods pro
and the beats and you combine them you
have the nice base from the beats not as
strong but close and the nice high
frequencies those detailed sharps from
the airpods pro and combined them and
gave something that's pretty much right
in the middle
that sounded fantastic i really enjoyed
it the volume was good in the past it's
a little bit too quiet with the the
samsung buds nice okay that was good it
sounded great on all three the bass on
here
if you love bass
you're not gonna be disappointed but
let's go ahead and move over to the next
track the classical modern instrumental
[Music]
okay okay
wow okay i'm even more impressed
the highs here were nice the beats for
this song there's just not enough high
end there i wish we could just eq them
you know if they had an app that you can
uh change that these that wouldn't
change at all those sounded fantastic we
had the bass that the beats the studio
buzz do a little bit less but the
perfect amount those were a little too
bass heavy the highs were nice and crisp
like the high hat maybe a little bit too
crisp but when we had all that at the
end blending together there was no
distortion i was waiting for that no
distortion that little sweep sounded
super clean
these sound fantastic samsung
you guys are doing a great job and now
for the last song the most difficult one
tons of instruments tons of sounds we
got this rock track let's take a listen
[Music]
[Applause]
i see it coming
all right that was very interesting
gosh i was just a little disappointed
after that song and the first two songs
these guys did fantastic before rock
i don't know the base was there it was a
lot more rich than the airpods the
airpods do not have enough bass for rock
tracks if you want to hear the bass
guitar and the drums really kicking you
the vocals were very audible maybe a
little bit too much and instruments just
sounded like they're blending together
from the keyboard to the guitar to the
vocals you didn't have as much
separation now the galaxy buds killed in
this test that base is there i'd like a
little bit more highs but you do have
good separation and it just sounds great
for rock music so overall
if you want if you listen to rock i
would go for these amazing i've used
these so much these they're okay
not great a little bit underwhelming for
rock music and the airpod pros no
distortion they sound good they just
need some more bass so other than rock
the other songs we listen to having more
classical where you don't have as much
instruments
electronic a wide variety of songs they
do good but if you have something that's
very difficult with a lot of different
kind of sounds blended together that's
when they start to fall apart and now
for the last test a very important one
microphone quality we know that the
airpods pro sound fantastic the beats
studio buds sound like garbage but where
are the galaxy buds 2 going to fit into
that space let's go ahead and take a
listen this is a microphone quality test
using apple's airpods pro in a room that
has an average amount of noise and this
is the microphone quality of apples
beats studio buds in a room that has an
average amount of noise and this is the
microphone quality of samsung's new
galaxy buds 2 in a room that has an
average amount of noise all right guys
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below we just
transferred the audio files and took a
listen for ourselves and wow
there could not be a greater difference
between the buds 2 and the beats studio
buds these studio buds sound terrible
there are no high end at all mostly bass
a lot of rumble and noise whereas the
samsung buds 2
they denoise all of the low end there's
a very little low end sound a lot of
highs but the highs are very crisp very
easy to understand you will not have any
issues with people hearing you when
you're talking to them when you're using
these buds too and that makes sense why
the transparency mode or the ambient
mode why the highs were just they're
standing out so much is because of the
microphones but it is worth it for call
quality these are going to be great
whereas where with the beats studio buds
after about five times the people
telling me they couldn't hear me at all
i just decided every time i'm getting a
call i'm pulling these out and switching
to my phone and that is annoying of
course airpod pros no issues these
things kill it they have good bass and
good highs so if you're gonna do web
conferencing face timing whatever you
want to sound good recording audio these
things absolutely destroy so there you
guys have it what is the overall verdict
well the airpods they're good overall
they do have some downfalls but they are
more expensive 100 more msrp at least 50
bucks more if you're looking on the
market for the best prices we have
linked those linked down below but
they're almost two years old pretty much
two years old the speakers the sound
quality could be better between these
two if you're listening to bass or rock
and the thing you care about most is
just sound quality these are good
comfort are also good but no wireless
charging worse battery life microphones
suck there's a lot of limitations
whereas these new samsung butts too they
are such a well-rounded uh set of
earbuds sound quality is nice and
balanced more balanced than the beats
and i don't know you can't really go
wrong you have the wireless charging
they they do a good job the microphones
are great so i will actually be using
these and testing them out just like i
usually do we'll see what happens as far
as long-term comfort in the full review
but other than that overall i am
impressed with samsung they're putting
these out pretty much every like six
months compared to years and years for
apple but they are getting it right so
thank you guys for watching click that
circle above if you guys want to
subscribe and see that review and to
help us reach our goal of a million
subscribers check out one of those great
videos right over there that's been max
and i'll see you in the next video
[Music]